Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 1st,
2016 what's going on?
There you go.
The first month of the year is out of the way in all Billy booze bag has been
doing really well.
All right.
Last time I got hammered.
Last time I got hammered was a the last date versus he was out here visiting me
whatever fucking day that was.
It was like the second or 3rd of January.
And um,
I didn't drink for the rest of the month other than the fact I had eight beers
leftover from the rose bowl.
So I just drank like one a day for eight straight days.
Um,
always wanting a second,
forget about a third in a ninth fear.
But I,
uh,
just,
I just had one that was it self,
it's not bad for me.
You know,
I went like three weeks without drinking and eight straight days only had one
beer.
And then yesterday I didn't have any beer in the fridge.
I might have a Guinness left,
but I didn't drink it.
So,
uh,
you know,
we were out here.
What was Sunday?
It was fucking raining to beat the band.
Is that the fucking expression?
The play,
the band?
I even know what it was fucking porn out here for like legitimately the almost
the entire day.
Um,
which is great.
We could probably use about 90 more of those days,
but that was good that that was happening.
So,
um,
I just fucking stayed home.
Didn't do shit.
Last time I did Joe Rogan's podcast,
he gave me some elk meat that he had a,
he fucking killed an elk.
He murdered it premeditated.
The man got in his car and said,
I'm going to kill a fucking out,
but he didn't know which one,
so we can only get them on second degree murder.
And I became an accessory to the murder when I agreed to take some of the
carcass office heads.
Uh,
no,
he just gave me these two like giant,
like softball sized things,
the elk,
and they'd been sitting in my freezer.
So a,
I heard the meat's really lean and that it could be a little gamey.
So I just looked up some recipes and there was something there for like elk,
Chile and uh,
so I,
uh,
I made that yesterday and uh,
and it was fucking delicious.
But of course the lovely Nia goes out there and be like,
is this done?
This doesn't look done,
this doesn't,
I guess I'm just not used to Chile with this like consistency.
This smug looks more like a stew because there wasn't any tomato paste in the
recipe.
It was still delicious.
It was definitely a little more watery.
So she had to go out and go fuck with the whole thing and I'm eating the one
that I made and I'm enjoying it.
She just keeps it light in the other room,
just kept going,
like know,
I just think I do play for thought or whatever,
then fine.
I was just like,
will you shut up?
It's fine.
Fucking time.
I go out in the kitchen,
she fucking nitpicks whatever the hell it is that I'm making,
it's fucking unbelievable.
She makes something,
I eat it.
How was it adds good.
Go out there and go to the fucking spice rack.
You know,
it's,
it's rude,
it's rude.
So we got into it,
you know,
as we always do,
right.
Get into it a little bit.
Then she laughs,
tell me to go fuck myself.
And then she gave me her virtue with the tomato paste and you know,
I say,
Oh yeah,
I see what you're saying.
I like it.
You know,
that,
guess what I really felt.
I felt the first one tasted better.
She thinking that all up with this fucking tomato paste and they made it like
sweeter and,
uh,
you know,
did it to the whole fucking pot.
So,
you know,
we had a giant pot of it,
so I was like,
well,
I can handle what the fuck she did to it.
If it's just mine,
I got to eat the whole pot.
So I just rolled with it.
Just one of those times you just sit quietly and you nod.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's what you did over there.
All right,
I'll approve that.
You know.
Anyway,
um,
underrated elk.
Me.
Okay.
Got It.
Thrown out there.
Just fucking delicious.
So then we fucking sitting there.
I take my dog out.
There's a little a break in the um,
yeah.
And the wind,
the weather.
So I take my dog around the block and uh,
Blahblahblahblahblah and I come back in and he is like,
Hey,
you know what?
Why don't you want to have a pot cookie?
And I was like,
no,
I don't.
I got the podcast to do,
I got some bills,
mail and shit I have to do.
She's like,
come on,
it's fucking raining.
We're not going anywhere.
This is a perfect day to have a pot coke.
He's like,
I don't like,
that shit gets me too fucked up.
I feel like I'm hallucinating.
I don't want to do it.
And she goes,
no,
these are really mild.
These are really mild.
I know everybody out to fucking consumes those things right now is laughing
though.
They really mild so guy,
fine.
So I fucking eat this thing
right.
And it comes on really slow.
It's mellow.
And on my card I can deal with this,
just sort of just be chilling out and be relaxed and then all of a sudden just
fucking to the Moon Alice.
Right.
It's like fucking tripping.
Not like literally,
but it was just like,
you know,
I closed my eyes and my feet would feel like they would nine miles away from me,
you know?
And uh,
that was it.
I took it in the afternoon like around four o'clock by five o'clock.
That was it.
The day was over.
So now here I am,
I've got a bunch of shit to do it.
I'm trying to cram this crap and then I really don't,
I don't like it.
Um,
potheads idea of what mild is,
is not,
you know,
now I'm sure I'm going to get a bunch of fucking,
get a bunch of fucking emails from people going like this.
You want this sativa Fuckin a Asian and fused strain,
a weed man.
I just don't give a fuck.
All right.
I mean,
I was like,
just,
I was TV just dying,
laughing at everything that fucking came on there.
My wife made some cornbread with the Chili and I started doing like a cornbread
commercial,
you know,
hey guys,
what's better than a,
than a bowl of Chili.
That's right.
A nice piece of cornbread high.
Do you know me of sure.
We all do.
I was just doing that shit and I was the funniest shit ever to me.
And they was looking at me like,
what the Fuck's wrong with you?
And I'm like,
what do you mean what's wrong with me?
You fucking drugged me.
I swear to God.
You know what I think it was.
I think the horror of me being around for 24 hours with that,
whether she got like cabin fever and she literally dragged me because she was
able to handle it fine,
which is making me think she took less and she was just sitting there watching
TV and I'm saying all this shit that's making me laugh.
And she's just sitting there totally quiet.
I like,
I go my Bob and over here she was just like,
no,
no.
I hear what you say.
And I'm just watching the show and I like,
how are you that fucking
like,
I'm still a little fucked up right now at 24 hours later.
I Dunno.
So anyways,
that's why I like alcohol.
It's slowly comes on.
I know where it's going.
It wasn't like he grabbed a beer and you're this,
so I wonder what this does.
What's the end now that this,
this is a mellow drunk and then all of a sudden you get like fucking 20 times
drunker than you wanted it to be.
I mean,
that can start,
that can happen I guess with hard stuff.
MMM,
I did.
I don't know.
I just feel like the amount of fucking edibles you have to have to start to
understand what they do.
It,
it's just not fucking worth it.
So,
uh,
that was my one pot cookie for the year.
But anyways,
I haven't had a cigar since the eighth.
Um,
so I did it.
I'm trying to be too cigar a month guy.
And I did it in January.
I had one at the rose bowl and I had one on the eighth and then a,
now I've got a whole fucking month ahead of me.
So rather than smoking on the first,
you know,
I'm just going to fucking chill here for like a week to 10 days.
And then I'd have to figure,
I got to,
I could smoke.
Really just taking you through my whole fucking a bad habit.
A schedule,
their own.
I um,
I was speaking to cookies by the way.
I bought two boxes of girl scout cookies from this lay,
you know,
it's never the girl scout anymore knocking on the door.
Thank God.
Thank God with all the,
the uh,
to catch a predator.
They probably got sick of getting the door fucking slammed in their face.
Dig Dog.
He opened the door.
Hi,
I'm selling girls.
Got The door,
fucking yelling at your dog.
You saw nothing happened.
So anyways,
um,
now that just sorta sold by adults as far as I know.
So I got two boxes of these fucking things and um,
I just finally realized the amount of time that I've always felt like the girl
scouts made the cookies because they would call girl scout cookies.
And just somewhere maybe in the middle of this country,
somewhere around Fort Knox,
like the,
uh,
the United League of,
of American dos girl scouts has their headquarters and they just had these giant
tubs where they just stirred up cookie batter once a year and they got him out.
And,
um,
okay.
After finally thinking about it and looking at the professional packaging,
um,
yeah,
I'm going to go out on a limb here and I want to say,
I don't think,
I don't think any girl scout's make any of those fucking cookies.
I think they fucking outsource it,
right?
Yeah.
It's probably made by children.
Central America.
Okay.
They sit there crying,
how hard they have to work,
knowing they're never going to get a bite,
you know?
And then one of them actually steals a cookie and there's some psychotic
disciplinary action that's taken.
Let's Google this shit,
Huh?
Shall We?
This is like the new segment now.
They'll just,
you know,
back in the day,
she's just talk now.
I'm actually going to look it up here.
Who makes girl scout cookies?
Okay.
All right,
girl scout cookies.
All right.
Girl scout cookies or cookies sold by girl scouts.
I'll thank you.
Thank you.
Wikipedia girl scouts of the USA or a GS USA as one of its major fundraisers for
local scouts units,
members of the girl scouts of America,
but selling cookies since 1917 girls who participate can earn prizes for their
effort.
Fuck you.
That's my name.
Alec Baldwin comes in and screams at him.
All right.
The first cookies sales was by as scouting union missile,
the missile tow troop in Oklahoma and December,
1917 at their local high school in 1922 girl Scout magazine,
the American girls,
the American girls suggested cookie sales as a fundraiser,
blah,
blah.
From 33 to 35 crunchy,
wise,
organized cookie sales grew with troops in Philadelphia in New York City using
the cookie selling model,
so they're cooking their own ones.
Okay.
World War Two they sold calendars.
Yeah.
In 1990 the National Council limited the bakery's providing cookies to Jess,
ABC bakeries,
a division of inner Interbake foods.
Oh wait,
I skipped over something.
In 1950 [inaudible] more cookie recipes were added short breads,
peanut butter sandwich,
and thin mints.
The classic,
it's like the Beatles,
Zeppelin,
and the who of cookies.
Six types of cookies were being sold nationwide.
Okay,
great.
A cookie sale due to the baby boom generation,
they needed more.
The Samoa was added and 75.
All right,
whatever.
So ABC bakers was making in the 1990s and little Brownie Baker's little Prouty
Baker's a division of the key book company.
In 1998,
cookie sale awards were instituted with the 2005 trans fat controversy.
The girl scouts moved to make the cookies healthier and provide nutritional
information on the box.
In 2009,
the number of thin mints Dosey Dose and Tag Tag alongs and each box was reduced.
Why in the lemon chalet creams became smaller because of the increasing cost of
ingredients and transportation.
All right?
So the,
the,
there,
they tried to make it with less,
uh,
less trans fats.
Here's 10 weird girl scout cookie facts and then I'll get off this fucking
subject eyes dry mouth from that fucking cookie last night.
Okay.
Hey,
when they legalize
like
pot at a federal level,
do you think that they'll actually have girl scout like pot cookies?
You know Jesus Christ.
That'll be a field day.
What's happening to this country?
I'm a it salad.
Drugs.
All right.
Number one.
These cookies are older than your grandmother.
That's not weird.
Yeah.
Sound weird to,
you can make the original recipe at home.
You can make the original recipe of everything at home.
If you know the recipe.
Do you feel like taking a trip back in time and faking some boring stuff?
Oh,
this must be one of these hipsters sites where they're over everything,
including making fucking cookies.
You can try the authentic or they actually liked making the cookies,
but they're anticipating being insulted.
So what they do is they make fun of themselves first.
So you can't authentic original girl scout cookie recipe.
It's not in the respite recipe,
but they taste better if you dress up as a girl scout when you make them all.
That's a little internet joke.
Only two companies make the cookies.
Honey booboo is banned from selling them.
Thin mints are aren't just delicious.
They're mandatory.
I don't know what that means.
There is a cookie queen and she's a master sales woman.
Okay.
Oh,
there's a non sanctioned girl scout cookies.
Weed strain.
Of course.
Girl scout cookies used to cost less than a quarter.
Yeah,
everything costs less.
Okay.
There was a cookie shortage during World War Two.
Of course.
Yeah.
Not every cookie made the grade.
Oh Jesus.
That was disappointing.
All right.
Can I apologize Phil wasting the last fucking 15 minutes you life talking about
girl scout cookies.
Um,
did anybody watched the NHL?
All Star Gay fucking three on three hockey dude.
It was actually pretty entertaining but not quite as exciting as I thought it
was going to be because no one was going to take the body dude.
But it was still cool and obviously seeing John Scott score a couple of goals,
it's fucking hilarious at the NHL.
Didn't want him in there after all the money that they've made on fighting and
all the shit that of goon goes through,
you know,
the fact that the fans liked him enough to elect him into the game.
Right.
Daddy gets fucking traded.
Sit down to the midas and they told them not to show up.
Then he blogged about it like a seventh grade check and everybody went,
Dude,
what the fuck?
And then he was there and then he scored two goals.
It was like a Hollywood fucking movie.
Hey,
any non hockey fans?
Did you actually sit down and watch the All Star game?
It's everything that you would have liked a zillion fucking goals.
No fighting,
nothing physical people smiling after running into one another.
Was it dumbed down enough for you?
They're fucking who?
Peds.
Um,
I actually only watched the first period.
It's,
it appeared like the first period was only like 10 minutes long.
Is that true or was I under the influence of a plot cookie?
Um,
but anyways,
oh,
exciting news here.
Exciting news for me.
Um,
I'm actually doing a Gig in Cheyenne,
Wyoming now,
Wyoming is the last state that will fucking,
Billy red face has never performed in.
And at this point,
um,
I will have performed in all fucking 50 states.
And uh,
that being the fact that,
I don't know,
I have a little that OCD right?
Is that what it is?
No,
I don't know what it is.
I just like,
you know,
at first I was like,
you know what?
I'm going to go to every baseball stadium.
Then it became immediately goes,
I'm going to go to every fucking stadium that exists,
you know?
So if I start doing standup and then it becomes,
oh,
I did,
I've done three states.
It immediately I have to do every state and then it becomes a,
I have to do every continent,
you know,
except for like Antarctica or like places that don't want me.
Right.
But anyways,
I'm going to be a,
I'm going to be in Cheyenne,
Wyoming.
I'm going a bit,
first of all,
I'm going to be in Denver,
rocky mountain high.
And please don't bring me any fucking pot cookies.
All right.
I don't enjoy the,
I,
I don't,
I okay.
I just,
it's too much on the 12th and 13th I believe the,
uh,
12th and 13th is Wyoming and Denver,
Denver,
Wyoming,
I don't know which one.
And then the 14th is Valentine's Day.
And that's of course when a young people go out because they're not smart enough
to realize that,
uh,
that you can say,
I love you on any day of the year.
You know,
what's a great day to go out?
Go out on like the 17th
or the 16th to the 19th or the 21st.
Don't go out right before,
go out after brought after I say this every fucking year.
You know,
look at this.
The Superbowl this year is on the seventh and the fucking Valentine stays on the
14th.
Now those are two absolutely absolute shit show days.
Now obviously if your own fucking football team is playing in the Superbowl,
you know,
you're this,
you're going to want to watch it with a couple other fence,
right?
However,
that doesn't mean that you're going to,
you go to one of those shit show fucking Superbowl party.
So like I said,
as always,
take the fucking game.
Let it go for a good 90.
Then you come in,
you sit down,
you blow through all the commercials,
you blow through the fucking halftime show.
Fast forward to all of that shit.
And then,
uh,
when the game really starts getting down to it,
you know,
you're,
you're caught right up.
You'll catch up and like the beginning of the,
uh,
the fourth quarter,
then he can just kind of watch it in real time.
It's fucking perfect.
And you know,
blow your whole afternoon.
Oh fuck.
Sorry guys.
No more pot cookies for me.
Um,
and then the a and the 14th st thing,
just wait like two,
three days after
when he can get a fucking reservation.
Do,
you can go to the restaurant you want to go to and they haven't jacked the
prices up to the fucking roof.
Um,
and then you're done.
Right?
He's a good one,
right?
Because guys,
we usually don't get shit on Valentine's Day.
So,
uh,
I suggest don't get your wife shit either.
Just take her out to dinner and fucking leave it at that.
And if she's like,
I thought you were going to get me something else,
just be like,
well,
did you get me something else?
And when she's like,
no,
you be okay.
Well,
I paid for dinner.
That's it.
And that guarantees that you'll be in a fucking awful fight on Valentine's Day.
How do you like that?
See what I'm steering steering you towards?
Um,
for the life of me,
Bill burr coming to Cheyenne Civic Center to 11 the fuck are you talking about?
I can't be right.
Bill Burr will perform it.
The Cheyenne Civic Center in Cheyenne,
Wyoming on Thursday,
February 11th.
All right,
so then on the 12th I must be a Denver.
Is that right?
Jesus Christ.
Bill,
how do you have,
why don't you fucking know your own goddamn schedule?
DENVER,
I had to go skiing when I'm out there.
You know,
I skied once every 10 years.
I really should take a lesson cause that,
that is just the blow.
You fuck yes.
The 12th all right,
so the 11th Thursday,
I'm in Wyoming in February 12th I'm in Denver.
Ah,
that's how it is.
Very nice.
So there you go.
The Cheyenne Civic Center,
you know,
they always have fucking rodeos and shit.
They're right.
What goes on there,
Toby?
Keith,
Cheyenne,
civic center civic set up to be like some old ABA building
damages.
Jesus Christ.
Look at Cheyenne.
This looks like a fucking opera plays there.
An opera bill,
an orchestra.
Um,
the shade
go to Cheyenne,
Wyoming.
What are some of the great things that happened in Wyoming over the years?
Huh?
Only thing you always hear is bad stuff isn't that place with a will.
They tied that kid cause he was gay to the fence until he died.
This isn't good.
They don't have any sports tapes.
The fuck am I going to Wyoming for Wyoming?
This is where like Ted Turner can ride his horse all over the place and be like,
I own that.
I own that to get off of there.
Okay.
Or I'll take you out of Yardi,
your basic cable package.
Take my fucking TV Outta here.
Um,
don't ever start any shit with Ted Turney and why?
Ohmic all right.
Okay.
Cause he's going to come and arrest you and then he's going to be the judge and
he's going to throw you a g on.
It's the whole fucking state.
Does he?
Yeah,
I believe he does,
right?
I Dunno.
Anyways,
let's get to the fucking reach here for this week.
Mobilly all over the place.
Okay.
All right.
What do we got here the first week?
Oh,
look who's back,
everybody.
Sherry's berries.
Uh,
must be a clam day coming up.
Oh yes it is.
Valentine's Day is next week.
Finding the right gift can be tricky.
Uh,
tell a personal story relating to Valentine's Day.
Well,
you know,
I think it's bullshit.
You know,
I always hated it.
What?
I was fucking younger.
I think everything's a overpriced and everybody just sits,
stay a look at around at everybody,
you know,
and then somebody gets proposed to and they're like,
oh my God.
And then,
you know,
even if you've already proposed to the one year with this still kind of fucking
jealous and sad,
you know,
for then you just sit there splitting a dessert.
That's the part I hate the most.
Just sitting there splitting dessert because that means I've wanted to leave for
at least an hour and 10 minutes.
I just feel like you're distant tonight.
Um,
oh,
he's an example of the story.
Why you give Valentine's Day gifts,
getting the wrong gift to getting the right Gif.
Horror stories of waiting until the last minute and et cetera.
I don't think you should get him a gift.
I don't think you should get them anything more than Sherry's berries.
The fuck are they getting you?
Where is the copy for what the lay is going to get the guy,
this is such a fucking bullshit.
This,
this,
this whole holidays.
Completely fucking sexist.
And I,
you know,
you'd like to hear more,
a little chatter from the fucking feminist ladies there about this,
you know,
why are you taking me out?
Why don't I take you out every other year and then I get you a gift.
Come on ladies.
Let's have an even playing field,
right?
All right.
You want to give something unique that she'll love,
but you don't want to spend a zillion dollars.
You know,
you want to say,
Hey,
I'm really like you.
You know,
I really like you,
but I'm not quite in love with you yet,
but I'd like to get you to continue fucking me.
What would be a perfect gift?
Sherry's berries,
freshly dipped strawberries from Sherry's berries starting at only 1,999 it's
over 40% savings.
That's less than a hookah,
and if you don't want,
if you really want hero status,
you can double the berries for just 10 bucks.
Just go to Barry's dot com click on the microphone and type in my code.
B U r are these strawberries are picked at the peak of freshness.
Now they're not.
They never are.
They fucking get yanked and then they throw them and they ripen on the truck.
They ripe.
They're all fruit ripens on the fucking truck without the nutrients from the
vine to ensure the best gift experience there are huge and dipped in white milk
and dark chocolate.
He goodness.
Top with chocolate chips,
chopped nuts and decorative swizzle delivery is always guaranteed.
Oh,
we'll get them there.
We just don't know when.
Here's the only way to get these amazing balance,
this amazing Valentine's date deal,
juicy,
huge,
and freshly dipped strawberries starting at just 1999 or double the berries.
You fucking whore for $10 more.
Visit berries.com please spell out the word Barry's,
B E.
R R I e S.
Dot com.
Click on the microphone on the in the top right hand corner and type in Barbie.
You are our go to Barry's dot com click on the microphone and enter my code
today.
B u.
R.
All right,
pro flowers.
Look who's here?
Everybody.
Little candy and flowers.
You ought to buy an old school outfit too.
Little Derby three piece fest,
three piece suit,
I should say with the vest,
a little pocket watch.
All right.
PLO pro,
flowers,
sometimes parentheses.
Okay.
All the time.
It's hard for us guys to say what we feel.
What if there was a gift that said,
said it for you?
Jesus.
[inaudible] sexist.
This shit is yet to fucking dumb to say what you're thinking.
Why don't we handle it while with a bunch of Shit we ripped out of the ground?
Imagine a gift that was thoughtful,
easy,
and she'd love and that set your message perfectly.
All in one.
It's a beautiful flowers.
They're beautiful like you.
I call that a win on Valentine's Day.
Tell a personal story relating to Valentine's Day.
Well,
I always thought it was fucking bullshit.
I always thought it was a bullshit fucking holiday.
You know,
you pay way too much money and then halfway through some other woman gets
proposed to it.
Even if you're already proposed,
the young woman,
she's still look it over.
They're like,
oh,
you don't feel like I'm the fucking queen of the ball.
They really liked these personal stories.
Example,
why you give Valentine's Day gifts,
getting the wrong gift.
Jesus has saint people write this shit.
Pro Flowers I the flower pros that make valentines day easy.
Trust pro flowers and get this year done right.
Pro Flowers is offering my listeners plus any other podcasts.
They advertise on 100 blooms of love plus a free glass vase for just 1999 plus
this week only you'll get free chocolates for when you order for by Friday.
Ah,
they're down to Sherry's berries.
Turf.
There's going to be a fucking war.
Go to proflowers.com and use my code Bar B U R R proflowers is quick and easy
and delivers for Valentine's Day deliveries.
So Valentine's Day is guaranteed.
Pro Flowers are guaranteed the last seven days or your money back.
It's a no brainer.
Here's the only way to get amazing valentines day.
Amazing Valentine's Day deal,
including the freak chocolates.
Go to pro flowers.com.
Click on the blue microphone and the top corner.
Type in bird,
that's proflowers.com.
Click on the microphone and type in my code bar.
You must order by Friday,
right?
Midnight in order to get this deal.
Wow.
That's going to be an issue.
Huh?
They cutting right into Sherry's berries.
Sherry's fucking berries.
Well there's only one more here so I might as well plow through it.
No,
no,
there's two more.
All right.
We'll split it up.
Uh,
you know,
I was actually debating watching the Superbowl by myself and doing a little bit
of commentating during the game.
You guys seem to enjoy that.
Um,
maybe I'll do commentating during the shittiest most boring parts,
but then I'd have to sit and watch it like whoever's opening and I know stings
playing the halftime show and as much as I want to go see him and,
and Vinny,
Kali you,
it is on my bucket list.
Like that's not the right band for halftime at the Super Bowl.
Huh?
Okay.
Every breath you take every day move you make,
he's going to have to go more uptempo shit.
What do you think stings going to play from his repertoire?
Huh?
And thing off 10 summer tails.
But that's not the queen of my heart.
No,
that's not the shape of Maha.
I can't play that song
found out now,
but double,
double bounce.
[inaudible] and what's,
I was at Boon Doga Danco
fucking song was that then there was a song about the brothers,
the one that he was a coward.
None of that is going to play.
Well,
it probably plays synchronicity.
Yeah,
right.
You had a football game that stadium rock.
Did you set that goal?
Whoa.
Right.
Bunch of old baby boomers.
Second along,
bunch of kids go.
And that's not dubstep.
Um,
they had,
dude,
I want to fast forward through all that shit.
Yeah.
I'm thinking about maybe commentating on some of that stuff.
I'll just do like,
uh,
maybe I'll just do like three minutes,
not the game,
you know,
cause I think it will get boring after awhile,
you know?
Um,
at least if I'm going to get bored of myself,
I would think that you guys would get bored.
No.
Um,
all right,
let's plow through here.
So I don't have any booze in the fridge,
so I'm just,
I guess the month of,
uh,
I sorta half ass committed to this.
Like not posing.
Yeah.
Is that a bad thing?
A fuck is the other,
oh,
there it is.
Sorry.
Um,
talks about everything.
Pot cookie raining out here.
Shane.
Oh,
I haven't been on the fucking road and weeks,
so,
um,
I might be doing wink wink.
Oh,
I am doing a show this week.
That's right.
I'm doing the DDL Rag del Ray at the El Rey.
Oh,
JJ.
I'm a night of comedy and rock a Dean Del Ray's 50th birthday party.
He's going to have,
um,
you know,
he's going to have Joe Rogan,
crystal,
Leah,
myself.
Um,
I know there's a couple of other comics.
A Red Band is going to be down there and I want to say,
I want to say there's maybe one other comic.
And then after that,
uh,
Dee del Ray's gonna front a band that will include the likes of Rudy Sazo,
Dave Cushner,
Dave Lombardo,
Tracie guns,
Gilby Clarke,
all these rock stars and he's going to sing the entire highway to hell album.
And uh,
oh Billy red faced might sit in for a song or two,
but it's going to be a great night.
You can get tickets@agoldenvoice.com.
And also,
um,
I might be doing a,
a,
a surprise show somewhere locally because I got to run my hours.
So when I go to Cheyenne,
Wyoming or not get out there,
check out spread,
I want to make sure the thing that'd be on my game.
I don't want people in the crowd being like,
what the fuck,
man,
you made us wait to be number 50 for that bull shit walking around.
And they had John Denver fucking cheap coach.
Right.
Get the sheep lining rocky Matt and had Colorado bail.
We don't talk like that.
We'll talk like this.
That's all.
Wow.
All about.
I'm going to the Capitol Man.
Do they have open carry in Wyoming?
You know what,
I made such a big deal about open carry in Texas and a,
it turns out that they've had it in Oklahoma for years and there hasn't been a
fucking problem.
So,
um,
that's kind of a non story.
And then again,
I think that kind of adds to the touristy vibe of going to Texas and seeing
people walking around with holsters.
You know,
maybe you can see,
so you have somebody have a fucking shoot out over like a parking,
parking space,
a duel right draw.
Uh,
yeah.
Worst case scenario,
just a bunch of people that I don't know die,
which is a considering with global warming and overpopulation.
I think it's a good thing.
I think they should have open carry.
Uh,
they should have everywhere.
Everybody's strapped.
It would probably actually end up being safer when you think about it.
Cause I know like New York City for as much as everybody talks about how
dangerous it was.
Uh,
I just found on the,
on the subways,
we're all of a sudden you were riding in the car would fucking everybody.
It's all mixed up there.
There was a certain level of heightened courtesy because you didn't want to have
a fucking problem.
You know,
it's the subway is New York City.
You could get mugged,
you could get the shit kicked daddy.
So people fucking minded that business.
So I would think if he had a whole state of everybody walking around with a gun
on their hip,
you know,
somebody cuts you off in traffic,
Eh,
you know,
yeah.
I could yell,
you fucking Asshole boot up.
You start shooting at me.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Go ahead buddy.
I mean I have a gun too,
but you know what,
if I miss and you don't by all means go in front of me,
you know,
like if somebody is being weird to you and you're at one of those ATM sits on
the outside of a building.
Yeah.
It's a very nervous moment for you.
But if you're in your car and that same person cuts you off,
you're fuck you,
you fucking Dick a year.
You're all tough and your car,
which can lead to road rage.
Now if you know that that guy has a gun,
he could just simply,
you know,
pointed out the side of his car and just shooting the general direction of your
car.
You figure at the very least he's got to hit the radiator right.
You have that steam coming up like in every fucking movie.
Just the good old boy.
Right?
He probably going to mind your fucking business.
Maybe that's the secret to ending all wars.
Everybody strapped and you have the gun out.
He just walk in and every time you just walk you just,
the guns already pointed at somebody.
How you doing?
I'm doing good.
How are you?
Fine.
That's great.
Yeah,
keep the conversation short and sweet.
I think I just solve all of our,
all of our problems,
right?
Everybody's strapped with a gloated gun out pointed at somebody's safety off.
Okay.
Because you'd be more relaxed,
you know,
all they couldn't have safety off.
Cause then when people fell asleep,
you know,
it's like falling asleep.
I'll,
you know,
smoking,
you can let your bed on fire,
you might squeeze off around,
which doesn't even make sense,
right?
Cause you've got to put pressure on it once you have in one of those dreams,
you know?
Yeah.
But one of those dreams where you're falling or somebody just gives you a leg
sweep,
sweep she leg for whatever reason,
and you have to get fucking tense up.
Maybe then,
then you shoot yourself in the foot.
I bet podiatrist would be off the bet.
They're all for open carry,
you know the foot doctors.
All right,
you want me to do some reads for this week here?
Let's get into it.
Uh,
where are we?
Come on bill.
For God's sakes.
I was on the right one to begin with.
Oh Hey.
By the way,
does anybody know?
Like when I'll fucking,
for whatever reason,
you hit download an album off of iTunes and then for whatever reason it just
sort of disappears off of your phone and then fucking reappears because you
haven't hooked it up to the computer.
You know what I mean?
With phone.
And that makes it legitimately on your phone rather than just going through the
air or whatever the fuck is going on.
Right.
You know,
cause you've got the y Phi on and then the why Phi shuts off and then the album
disappears.
So then you're old like me see a downloaded again.
And then you got that album and then the,
the,
the two,
the first one comes back and now you've got doubles.
How do you get rid of the other one?
I've gotten into my iTunes and I've gone to delete it,
but on my phone it's still a double,
so I don't know how to do it.
So the song ends and then it replays again.
It plays everything twice.
That happened me with van Halen,
1984 and that NAS album illmatic 'em.
As much as I love both of those albums,
I don't need both songs to play twice.
How do I get rid of the other one?
If anybody can tell me,
I would really appreciate it.
All right.
Okay.
Kanye situation.
Hey,
Bill.
Red Blooded American male here who heard about the Kanye situation and was
scared shitless.
I'm not going to disclose whether or not I enjoy what he was accused of enjoying
a parentheses.
If you don't know the story,
his ex Amber Rose implied on Twitter that he enjoyed a finger in his ass.
Actually it was fingers,
plural.
Yeah.
I didn't hear about this fucking story and it may be feel good as a human being
that I was somehow out of the loop of this fucking news.
He said,
this scares me because it doesn't matter what you're into.
If an x says shit like that,
you're going to get branded.
Um,
so are you.
Sound like you're x.
Put a vase in your ass.
Anyways,
he goes,
it's how urban myths about [inaudible] get started.
Unless you're fearless Jim Norton and you can say something like that with a
smile on your face,
on the airways.
It's a pretty tough situation to be at.
How does a man like Kanye deal with that?
Uh,
I don't know.
I,
I went,
I started to read it,
but I,
it just,
I don't if it is true,
I don't give a shit
really none of my business before I could tell from the article he was talking
shit about her.
Now if she had half her head up,
his fucking acid,
some point is probably not a smart idea if he's sensitive about that part of his
sexuality to be talking Shit.
Right.
Which makes me kind of believe him
then it didn't happen
because you figure if she had that over him,
if she was walking around with them like a sock puppet,
right.
That he wouldn't go around talking shit about her.
I Dunno.
Gotta be honest.
It's one of those things that I,
I legitimately feel is none of my fucking business.
And uh,
whether it's true or not doesn't make me look at Kanye one way or the other.
I mean,
I don't give a fuck.
Give a shit what the guy does.
Okay.
And I also think a,
I don't think you walk around talking shit about,
someone used to go out with,
didn't work out.
Fucking grow up.
You're already married.
You found somebody else leave me alone.
Right.
I don't look,
I don't know what happened,
but all I know he was,
if,
if it's true that he was talking shit about her,
I probably should stop saying talking shit when we're talking about a finger up
your ass.
Um,
yeah.
You know what,
having said all that,
it's fucking hilarious.
MMM.
You know,
I would think that there's a lot of rival rappers right now trying to write down
words that rhyme with the phrase fingers up your ass.
Uh hmm.
Lingers in the class with fingers up your ass.
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
There's,
there's gotta be something that they're coming up with.
That's an easy one too.
Yeah.
If I was,
if I was a rapper and somebody said that my ex put fingers up my ass,
how all I would be thinking was like,
God dammit.
Why didn't she say rectum?
At least make it difficult to ride something rectum.
Check them.
You check them fingers up your rectum.
No fingers checked
through.
All clean going up your rectum.
Sorry.
Anyways,
um,
flashes.
I like that at all.
That's 100% on him.
What about how at this.
Thank you fingers.
Now Jesus Christ,
you got to go with the fist bump.
Now when you go the end,
when you run into amber,
give her the ll but more stay away from that.
Get a fucking tetanus shot.
Funny.
She shook her hand and then all of a sudden you just started fucking talking
shit about yourself the way Kanye does.
Um,
all right.
Classes.
Yeah.
Uh,
in high school,
uh,
hello.
You orangutang looking mother fucker.
I guarantee that this guy is the ugliest motherfucker.
I really find that people,
uh,
people who trashed the way I look the most,
especially on Twitter,
never have like their,
uh,
never have their picture.
I don't look like an orangutan.
Do I dare fucking older.
They look like old people.
Um,
in a housecoat uh,
I am a senior in high school.
Yeah.
Like a kid.
Oh you probably 18 at this point you're punk and this may seem childish to talk
about,
but I been thinking about dropping one of my classes,
this class is music theory,
a p and I'm a straight be studious students so I'm no genius.
I talked to my teacher and guidance counselor who both said it was fine to drop
it.
Music theory being a unique class
bows.
That appendix right there at the end there.
That didn't make,
that was all part of that sentence.
Anyways,
recently I came into school thinking,
uh,
that was the shit.
Like I came into school thinking that this shit was over and I wouldn't have to
take the class anymore.
Only they have the assistant principal of my school tell me that I would not be
able to drop at that.
This point I'm frustrated because I'm very unhappy in the class and the only
ones separating me from dropping the class is my prick of an assistant
principal.
Should I sack up and finish the rest of the year or should I stand up from my
case and become a stubborn prick and the process,
the class gives me anxiety and I'm not really into music anymore.
I'm thinking about picking up a second English class.
If the principal doesn't let me drop the class,
I would probably end up skipping it every day because I hate the class.
That fucking much am I in the wrong?
Any advice would be great bill.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Um,
oh,
when I was a kid,
when you went to high school,
you couldn't drop classes that happened in college.
You're a senior,
it's February,
don't you get out in like the middle of May.
Um,
and if you transfer it you have to make up the first two semesters or whatever
the fuck it is.
September,
October,
November,
December and January worth of shit.
And your second English class.
I just tough it out.
It's music theory.
I mean that sounds boring as shit.
Um,
but what I would just tough it up.
Okay.
I,
that's what I would do.
I mean,
I mean I would rather tough,
tough,
but when me and my were just speaking about myself personally,
but I rather tough out music theory than day.
Take another fucking English class.
But that's me.
Yeah,
Dude.
Just fucking tough it out.
What's it giving you?
Anxiety for it.
It's a music theory teacher.
It's not like they're going to be like,
so like the football coaches teaching it as e.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
Tough it out.
That seems like a class that even if he just halfway pay attention,
he can at least get a c.
Right.
I Dunno dude.
This fucking,
it's fucking hangover from this God damn cooking.
I mean,
I fell asleep last night at like six o'clock.
I slept for like 12 fucking hours.
I'm still exhausted.
All right.
Being Stung by shit.
Okay.
Hey Billy,
big freckle balls.
Love that.
You guys think I suck my nuts.
Uh,
your last podcast touched on being stung by spiders and Shit and you touched on
sting rays.
Uh,
those fucks that killed Steve Urban and I,
no,
no.
He fucked with them.
And the thing felt like it had to do to defend itself.
All right.
I'll tell you right now,
the rejoicing that wildlife did overall when the crocodile hunter got killed,
I mean,
the level of stress that he brought,
every animal that he came into contact with all,
see,
he's hunching up.
He doesn't like that.
The thing is in fear for his fucking life.
And you're going up and you're fucking with the thing so you can,
you know,
when you're little fucking booty shorts.
Anyways,
he goes,
I'm Canadian and I spent five minutes in an American ocean and was stung by a
sting ray.
Well,
all of your emotions are American to you live in North America.
We're all Americans.
But I guess once you say you're Canadian,
I'm United.
Okay.
I'm a Canadian.
I spent five minutes in an American ocean,
was stung by a sting ray.
It felt like a hot nail being driven through my foot and the pain went up and up
for hours.
It was the most painful thing I've ever experienced.
Uh,
let that be a lesson to all the listeners that sting rays are not something to
be fucked with.
Uh,
nothing can describe that pain.
It was insane.
Love the podcast.
Fuck you in Boston because they went so fucking always
cause they went so fucking always.
Um,
yeah.
Well you know,
this is the thing.
We're not supposed to be in the ocean.
Okay.
I want to say that again.
We're not supposed to be in the ocean.
We can't breathe in there.
We can't see what's beneath us were completely vulnerable when we go in there.
We're not supposed to be in there.
That sting ray has evolved to fuck up things that belong in the ocean,
all of which are way bigger and way faster.
Generally speaking,
some giant fish goes to fucking kill this thing.
Right.
It's got to have enough juice in its shank to make a Sharko away.
I would think so.
Yeah.
You come walking in,
you fucking pink feet.
Come walking in there.
If you're white,
right.
You go in there and you did just yet it's over.
So I'm surprised they don't got enough juice to kill you because I know Steve
Irving,
what happened him as he got stabbed in the fucking,
I think it punctured his heart.
What are the odds of that?
I wonder what his fucking last thoughts were.
Yeah,
he's folks are really fucking sting ray.
What was he just thinking?
Hi,
let me just pull this out.
I'm sure that'd be filed off.
Oh,
that's artery blood.
All right.
Love the podcasts.
Go Fuck you said.
You know what's funny?
Somebody Australia's can be offended that I'm actually fucking talk like they
haven't thought about this shit,
but isn't it like 10 years ago?
What is the statute of limitations when you,
uh,
deliberately go and fuck with the sting ray and get killed by that?
It's um,
that you can't keep talking about it.
All right.
Beer drinking contest advice.
Dear Billy,
beer bomb,
I'm a big fan man.
I to your podcast for a couple of years now and I had the chance to see you
Versie and bod nick at the Chicago theater.
Great show.
So I'd been roped into a beard.
Beer-Drinking Olympics parentheses for charity by a buddy of mine.
And being that I'm an old fuck,
not quite what you are.
I'm 38.
I was wondering if you have advice in terms of longevity backstory on me.
I'm a Canadian.
I'm a Canadian pocket square wearing a habs fan.
I know.
Fuck me.
Right?
I don't give a shit.
As long as you have a sense of humor about yourself that can really hammer them
back.
Bear is my first choice when I drank as I assume as yours.
What would you do to get ready for something like this?
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Um,
well you got to,
I would think,
aren't they going to be different events?
You know,
there's gotta be drinking beer.
There's got to be drinking hard stuff.
Is it all just going to be beer drinking?
Wait a second.
I was wondering if you have any advice in terms of longevity.
All right.
As far I thought you meant how to,
how to live long.
Do you mean how to hang in there?
Um,
well if it's a beer drinking contest,
then I would just drink hard stuff leading up to it.
You know,
a couple of beers and it had like your shots too,
you know,
I dunno.
Build up your tolerance.
This doesn't seem like this is a responsible thing for me to be telling you to
do.
I would be,
I would just go there and have a good time.
That's what I would do.
And I wouldn't try to win a metal.
You don't want to be the guy that wins that the guy wins.
That's going to have like fucking rosacea on the side of his face from booze and
you know,
it's going to look like fucking WC fields.
You don't want to be the guy that can win that contest.
I would say just go there and have a good time,
you know,
Eh,
stop short of being the guy that fucking pukes all over everybody.
That would be my advice.
Uh,
all right.
Let me do the last reads here really quickly and then I'll do the last question
is I'm fucking trying to shake off this.
God Damn yawning from that fucking cookie.
Come like overtired here.
All right.
Okay.
I have you guys been watching any of the Super Bowl pregame?
Why would you,
are they doing the old man versus the young man,
but for the Denver Broncos,
Holloway,
Stop Cam Newton,
newbies,
panthers of the fucking Carolina,
let's say about cab building is this guy is one of those rare talents that just
can hurt you on every level.
Okay?
He covers receivers.
No problem.
This guy is going to run it.
You're going to rush this guy.
You can't bring them dabble.
Just what guy?
You got to stand there and stare at him.
He's got to pick you apart.
I'll tell you right now,
I would not want to have this job as being a coach is Denver Bronco date fence?
Well,
like,
what are you saying?
Are you going to do,
who do we think the key the game is?
Deborah has to go to ball and they have to score it.
Really?
They got a score.
Often their best hope to control care noon is to take the pictures out of deer
gay plan.
If they're playing catch up all night,
you know what?
Dead,
Denver and Da da Da.
And you don't care.
You know,
I know Peyton Manning's older,
but this is still paid Manny.
Okay,
just last game.
I'll tell you right now,
he's a competitor.
He's going to get out there and although to peer teach you have a good defense.
They still are a young defensive unit.
Okay.
And then you'd watch that to come into play,
especially after they make their halftime adjustments.
Is that about it?
Something like that there can try to exploit the seeds.
Um,
what about special teams?
What about Peyton Manning's wife taking HGH?
What are the odds of that dollar shave club?
Everyone.
Lots of players will be sporting playoff beard.
Now that the post seasons here,
can you imagine if Jazelle was getting fucking HGH sent to the house?
I'm sure that story,
we're just disappear after a couple of moments.
Leave that to the pros.
Kickoff your year the right way with a fresh blade shave.
That's why me and when millions of others have joined the dollar shave club.com
revolution.
Dollar Shave Club knows that the key to getting an amazing shave,
it's simple.
One,
use a fresh dollar shave club blade to use their doctor cabbies.
Eez Shea,
bye.
That's it.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing razors right to my door for a third.
The price of those greedy mega razor corporations.
That means listeners who switched now can afford the luxury of shaving with a
fresh blade anytime and save hundreds this year.
And when you combine that fresh blade with their doctor,
ca Bzz Shea.
Wow.
It just glides.
Done.
Imagine we smooth.
I'm telling you,
it's not your average shave form.
It won't dry out your skin.
The all natural ingredients.
Leave your skin feeling soft,
smooth and moisturized after every shape.
Take it from me.
Use a fresh dollar shave club blade with doctor cabbies.
Easy shave butter if you want the most gentle shave imaginable joint,
Dell Shave club.com/bar today.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar.
All right,
stamps.com everyone.
You know what?
Sometimes it feel like sometimes it feels like there's just not enough hours in
the day,
even when you work or even when you're working past the nine to five.
That doesn't make sense.
So it's you're still making time consuming trips to the post office.
You need a better way.
You stamps.com with stamps.com gets postage to get the posted you need the
instant you need it by and print official us postage for any letter and package
from your computer,
a printer.
It's quick and easy.
You'll save money with stamps.com too.
It's just a fraction of the cost to one of those expensive postage meters.
Plus you'll get special postage discount.
She can't even find it.
The post office,
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters,
whatever I'm pouring myself out right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last name Barbie you are are for this special
offer,
a four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes postage and a digital
scale.
Get started with stairs.
Stop Cob today.
Today,
today.
Within minutes you'll be printing postage,
right your desk.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
took on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeitburburthatstamps.com enter
burr.
Alrighty,
mercifully is ended.
Um,
all right,
let's get back to a,
I got one more read here and then I got to wrap this fucker up.
It's time for me to go.
All right.
Dating in the workplace.
They Aka no GG
Billy fuckboy birth.
Oh Hey.
By the way,
I finished on the second season of top boy.
I highly,
uh,
I highly recommend it.
Um,
all right.
There's a lady in my workplace that I have a huge crush on,
but I fucked everything up by drunkenly telling her best friend at a company
holiday party that I had a crush on honor.
I say fucked up because I know how females communicate.
I might as well have just walked up to the girl I had a crush on and told her I
know from a past job,
but dating in the workplace fucks everything else up at work.
Had told myself I'd never do it again,
but for some reason my brain couldn't say no to this girl anyway.
I know this girl knows I like her from her best friend and it made our work
dynamic awkward just because when we interact now,
both of us feel like we have to fulfill some sort of role.
Okay,
well you should just walked up to it says,
Hey,
I got a little drunk.
I said some things to your girlfriend,
uh,
that you know,
I should have said to you die.
I can't say that.
That's two Ford.
Oh,
the office just makes it creepy.
You can't lean on anything as you're talking to her,
you might as well just you standing there rubbing your balls.
Aww.
This is situation.
One day I said fuck it and half assed or route to an art museum.
But she had friends in town said she couldn't.
What pisses me off is that I used to hang out with my coworkers and this girl
every now and then now,
no,
no one invites me to hang out.
When they do a background on the company,
it's under a hundred people and we're all in our twenties for the most part.
Uh,
what's the best way to pursue this girl in this situation and how do I mentally
handle the fact that it's affected my ability to hang out with my coworkers,
my other coworkers,
I really want closure to this thing,
whether it be a date,
whether I date her or she tells me she's done interested.
I don't care at this point.
I really don't like the tension at work.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Yeah.
Which says to me you don't really even like this girl.
Okay
Mike,
I just want to ask around,
get rid of the tension and then she says yes.
So she says,
no,
I really don't give a fuck at this moment.
This is what you do.
This is what you do,
sir.
He just just fucking blow it off.
Okay.
Just blow it off.
You don't give a shit.
Just act normal around her.
All right.
That she'll be gone like,
oh he doesn't give a fuck.
And then she'll probably end up being an interested in youth cause that's how
they fucking work.
All right.
I don't hang out with the people you work with.
Fuck someone you don't work with.
You need to create a social circle outside of work.
The people at work should be the people you see Monday through Friday.
Okay.
And then once Friday,
see you later guys.
Take it easy.
What are you doing?
I'm getting the fuck away from you,
right?
Then you go out,
you can do your fucking black tar heroin or whatever the fuck you want to do.
And then there's no awkwardness at the copier.
All right?
You already said the give you fuck somebody that you work with before and how
that made your last job awkward yet.
Here you go again.
And for some reason you're not even in a relationship yet and it's already
fucking up your coat.
Your uh,
okay.
Just your,
your interaction with your coworkers yet you want to pursue this thing too.
I would just let it go.
Just let it go.
And uh,
listen,
he want to fuck somebody at work.
Don't try and fuck them.
All right.
Just come in with a big smile on your face on Monday and everything.
You know,
nobody knows what the fuck you did and they're all hanging out with each other.
They're all gossiping with each other and eventually they're going to be
gossiping about you.
Hey,
I wonder what he does.
What's up with his exciting life?
You know,
you're coming in looking like you're out there banging away and fucking having a
great time going out on the town event.
She,
one of these broads is going to be fucking interested enough and then you know
what?
Your dumb ass is going to fuck her and then it's going to be awkward again.
Can't do it dude.
You got it.
You got to have a fucking do your social,
sir.
You're fucking,
and you're drinking and all that.
It has to be outside of work.
Um,
unless it's a guy,
okay.
It cannot be,
cannot fucking hang with women that you work with.
You can't do it because eventually your decks going to make you say something
stupid.
Something's going to happen.
Well that's going to get in the fucking way and it's just going to be a big be a
big God damn problem.
Uh,
same thing.
Don't hang out with your boss either.
Hang out with someone that's on your fucking level.
And even then,
dude,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't hang out.
You don't hang out with people you work with.
You know,
something always ends up happening.
Maybe you do something dumb and then your buddy can't keep his fucking mouth
shut,
you know,
and then it gets to somebody and then that year up for your,
your,
your review.
You don't get as much money.
You get passed over.
It's fucking stupid.
You were in your 20s,
you're going to make it,
you're going to make a bunch of fucking mistakes.
So don't do it with the people you work with.
All right.
Have I said that enough times?
Having said that,
okay.
Um,
you want my super bowl pick?
I actually liked the Broncos with the points if they getting six and don't
listen to me because I don't know anything about the Broncos coach,
but I know bill Belicheck with Peyton manning and that defense could figure out
a way to,
uh,
beat the Carolina Panthers.
And I know what a lot of you guys are thinking.
Well that defense in that coach and Peyton manning just beat your patriots and
Bill Bellacheck.
It's like,
well he didn't have the team,
you know.
Um,
my only is that Denver's defense isn't as good as it looked against the patriots
because a,
we had that Swiss cheese fucking offensive line.
We had injuries all that year and Carolina looks really healthy,
their offensive line looks really healthy.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
I think that bullshit that I actually said earlier where I was making fun of
those analysis,
those analysts is actually what I think Denver better hope that when the toss,
and I would say take the ball rather than deferring it and hopefully you march
down the field,
score seven,
give them a three and out.
I think,
I literally think that they then need to score again,
go up 10 [inaudible] this is my keys to the gay Denver.
When the toss they need to go out there,
it's somehow get it done and choose heads.
If it's going to be heads,
tails,
if it's going to be tails,
then they got a risk.
Take the fucking ball,
ram it down their fucking throats.
Yeah,
just obvious shit.
Nice time consuming drive and uh,
stablish the run.
Um,
I think Peyton could do all right against that defense if they,
if they,
uh,
you know,
if he has to fucking time.
See there's no way to say really bill,
what if he doesn't have the time?
Does that make it more difficult?
This is really hard.
This is really,
it's really hard to say something that isn't cliched.
Um,
my,
my concern is a Broncos fan is that the panthers get the ball,
they march right down the field and they score it because what's his face,
Peyton manning is,
is gloom and doom guy.
That guy gets that look on his face.
Peyton faces what?
Me and my family used to call it where he just,
he just purses his lips and he starts looking,
downfield shaking his head as he takes his fucking Chin strap off after yet
another three and out.
That's the,
that's the,
the headspace panthers want to get him in.
If he gets into the,
he gets into that.
Why isn't everybody as good as me mindset?
Uh,
it's fucking over.
So in order to keep him happy,
I'd say that they got a score or back to that again,
that Jesus,
maybe I'll come up with something on Thursday.
There you go.
Everybody that Bup,
Bup,
bup,
Odo,
Buddha.
I take the Broncos in the points.
I take six points.
Fuck it.
Cause every cunt out there is going to take the panthers every cunt out.
There's going to the is,
you're going to fucking destroy them.
That's when you want to go the other way because whatever that means that every
fucking shit at out there,
it's going to put money on the pant is,
which means the line.
We'll keep going up because Vegas is one.
Again,
this is going to want to get money on both sides of the ball.
Thank you bill.
Like we didn't know that.
I'll fuck you.
I'll talk to you guys on Thursday.
Go fuck yourselves.
And um,
don't fuck anybody you work with.